David we are coming off a series of
conflicts between Jesus and Jewish
leaders in Jerusalem and before that we
had seen a series of predictions by
Jesus that he was going to come into
conflict and before that we even back to
chapter 3 saw the Pharisees and
Herodians banding together to plot Jesus
death it's been building for a long time
and in chapter 14 we turn to that and
well what is the what it's the shape of
that culmination what what happens my
sense of this gospel and this is by no
means unique to me is that that this is
the point to which we've been moving
that insofar as we can kind of draw a
straight line through all the places
we've been the conflicts the parables
the miracles it's all driving toward
Jerusalem and it's driving toward the
cross and it's driving toward what
that's going to mean for us for the
readers and for us and in the centuries
that follow
just a couple kind of more technical
things about the way I think mark shapes
the story I think once again mark did
not make up this story it's a story he's
received it's a story that's been passed
on by word of mouth for a long time Paul
knows the version of it 20 years before
mark it's been passed down from the time
of the crucifixion and the resurrection
on but there a couple places where I
think ways in which mark shapes it and
it helps me to think about it to think
about this shaping what is that that the
story of the crucifixion part not so
much the trial but the crucifixion part
it's very much shaped by Psalm 22 and as
I go back and read some 22 the first
line is my God my God why have you
forsaken me which is the last word Jesus
says in all of Mark's Gospel says it
from the cross
there's the dividing of the closed as
the casting of laws that people walking
by daunting in all kinds of ways this
story gets told as as being foreshadowed
by Psalm 22 and it may be that that in
his wisdom or her wisdom the psalmist
somehow knew what was going to happen in
God's providence we've already said
God's in charge of this world that's
what we were talking about in chapter 13
maybe that mark hearing the story of the
crucifixion tried to find in earlier
texts a kind of foreshadowing
that could deepen it and enrich it and
help us to understand it is part of
God's providence but in either way I
think it's impossible to read Mark's
story of Jesus trial and especially of
his crucifixion without knowing that
Psalm 22 is being reflected there and in
some 22 the picture of the righteous
servant who suffers for God and is
vindicated by God though we don't get
that so clearly till we get to chapter
16 the other the other theme the other
device that's very important in mark all
the way through but especially in the
scenes of the trial of the crucifixion
is irony and and I've read books on
irony and I've threatened to write
paragraphs on I already and ironically I
never get it very right but but irony I
think presupposes that there's more
going on than meets the eye or more
going on than meets the ear that there's
a deeper truth than what's being
portrayed and that we who are the
readers or we are the listeners can
understand a truth that the actors the
players don't actually get so just to
make the most obvious example when when
Jesus is crucified Pilate puts up above
the cross the title the placard which
says King of the Jews and Pilate I'm
sure thinks that's absolute mockery
what a joke we're gonna call this loser
the King of the Jews but we who read
this through the eyes of faith of the
eyes of Mark say ah Pilate got it right
for the wrong reasons and and time after
time in Mark's Gospel people are saying
things that they think are taunts that
turned out to be confessions so after
the trial they robbed him in purple and
put a crown on his head and they some
kind of King this is isn't that silly
and we think ah that's that's the King
suffers that's the king who bears the
crown of thorns that's the true kingship
we've been talking about all along
that's the Messiah Peter didn't know how
to deal with but the Messiah Mark's been
telling us all along we're going to get
or the when he's when he's on the cross
people walk by and taunt him saying he
saved others he can't save himself and
they think how we got to Jesus you suck
but we think that's right that's that's
the Christian faith that by his
unwillingness to save himself he saved
others including us that his loss was
our gained and and so time after time
after time mark uses a kind of ironic
approach to try to get what's going on
that's that's to say how he shapes it
what he shapes that's trickier what's
well in one of the one of the things in
in your good comments on Psalm 22 and
how it might be shaping this narrative
one of the things that came to mind is
we didn't talk in chapter 13 the
apocalypse writer about how many times
these words it is necessary one big word
comes up it is necessary that this
happened and that's the same language
that Jesus uses in his passion will
suffer many things yeah yeah so there's
there's almost between those and the the
presence of Psalm 22 and the prayer in
the garden you know if it's possible at
this cover house there seems like
there's a sort of necessity built that
Psalm 22 embodies this is what it has to
be there really this is what has to be
yeah unless Jesus chooses not to do it
that if he used to be who he is to be
this has to happen and I think I think
that means two things at least it means
one this is God's intent and we are not
going to pause here for a long
discussion on what that means the
illogically because it's huge right but
it also means that if you read scripture
closely enough you'll know this is going
to happen so that all the more reason to
look to Psalm 22 I'll show you why it's
necessary I'm gonna read some 42 to you
if you read it right you'll see it sees
Jesus coming which he does mark does
much more subtly than Matthew if I was
ready to face this passage on mark mark
has it as this background time after
time after time which puts me in the
room with the people who are listening
and asking asking would they know so I
don't eat I don't know what do you think
how much how much is this laced in of
the way the early Christians talked
about the crucifix yeah it's that size
that's one of those good so it's a great
puzzle I just
yeah yeah in the in in the scenes
leading up we we probably should gather
the dissembling of the disciples that
happens at the supper and in the time
that follows when they're in the garden
yeah and the the question I have about
that is how how are we supposed to see
what faithfulness looks like to mark
yeah when so many people end up not
ready yeah it looks like the disciples
not faithful this looks like the
disciples not if you read the passion
story yeah whatever it is it can't
possibly be this yeah and and he sets
that up in interesting ways one
interesting way sets it up is to tell
the story of Peter in the courtyard
denying Jesus why they've got Jesus
inside affirming that he's the son of
man and and you clearly I'm one answer
is faithfulness looks like Jesus and
that's a really important answer right
it's harder to know what faithfulness
looks like with with the circle around
him and it's just it just compounds what
we've seen from the very beginning on
which is they've been dense all along
now they're cowardly
right the Jesus says they're gonna smite
the Shepherd and the sheep will be
scattered and then by heaven that's
exactly what happens the minute the
shepherd gets arrested the sheep head
for the hills yeah I know you know I
bring it up partly because we are coming
off chapter 13 where Jesus told the
disciples very clearly what they need to
do they need to stay awake to water and
be strong within the first bit off they
go cemani yeah they go snoozing news and
they start running away yeah and yeah
and so I mean I do think for an audience
in that ancient living room and for us
as audience it's okay to say Jesus is
what we need to be yeah but it's hard to
take on that character without
developing this messianic very tricky
and so you may be right maybe the best
way we can go within this stretch is
just don't do what the disciples yeah
the opposite of the flip side about our
hopeful picture of that is the man who
stands at the foot of the cross at the
end and he's a he's another though
people this is a Centurion and in
chapter 15 verse 39 he I'm gonna try to
kind of paraphrase mark but I think
pretty accurately when the Centurion
sees the way in which Jesus died he says
surely this was the Son of God and he he
becomes an illustration of that problem
we had earlier which is great to believe
for thirty-two seconds we have no idea
how that looks over the long haul but
for 32 seconds he does believe he does
get it right he doesn't say the cross is
the denial of your faithfulness he
doesn't say the cross is a threat to my
well-being
he says the cross dying that way is the
evidence that this man is son of God and
and and I think it's not unimportant
that he sees it it's not an important
that he's yet another outsider he's at
Gentile he's not only not part of the
inner circle he's not part of Israel
he's not been part of any of those
people have been either the opponents or
the cowards but he does looking at the
cross say truly this was God's Son and
he certainly doesn't know Psalm 22 and
it certainly does not know stop what he
do right and so so when this comes I
mean is there any part of you that
wishes is there any part of you that
wishes in this in this realization and
this recognition of the Centurion that
he were doing this with Jesus doing the
things that he does in Luke father
forgive them
no not what they do Jesus being a little
more exemplary because what what he is
on the cross here is desperate sounding
yeah if you don't know some 22 right
desperate sounding and then he he
breathes his last and something happens
down at the temple that the Centurion
can see yeah no no right the cemetery
the walk there's a little miracle going
on to the temple where the curtain story
the Centurion doesn't see that the
Centurions he saw he died Matthew and
Luke both try to play this down in
Matthew the Centurion does see that
stuff right and says whoop miracle Jorah
this was a son of God in Luke forget
that cry of abandonment my God my God
why be really good me I forgive you I
love you I'm on my way and then of
course everybody thinks it's lovely
because he's lovely right uh that why do
I love Mark's Gospel because this is the
final moment of honesty
that no Jesus doesn't just seem seem to
be abandoned Jesus is abandoned Lord and
Savior what do you feel I feel abandoned
why do you feel abandoned because I've
been abandoned right and and the power
of the story is family it deserts him
disciples desert him and then finally
God deserts him and he's left out there
hanging all alone and if you can say
hanging all alone son of God in one
sentence
you've got the mystery that's at the
heart of Mark's Gospel which is that the
the God who suffers in Jesus Christ is
the God who is present for us and that
is good news it's great painful as it is
it's great news and it mark sticks with
it with this Centurions realization mark
sticks with it mark trade on doesn't
blink for a minute he doesn't need to he
doesn't need to soften he do it starting
in chapter 8 right
anybody wishes to come out here's the
cross yeah here's the cross I'm gonna
take it on you take it on - its there's
no there's no sort of whitewash or
polishing or airbrushing here it's it's
just straight on the in the Centurions
realization we of course pick up as
you've said one one right now the
beginning of the gospel of Jesus Christ
the Son of God yeah demons I know who
you are the son of the Most High God at
the battle is another hearing ratio and
Jesus in the trial here right
are you the son of the the blood SIA is
that so what is it for a first century
reader what is it for us that the guy
who gets this is the Centurion yeah I
mean we've talked a lot about how mark
puts this directly and lets somebody get
it directly and doesn't need him to
forgive anybody on the cross but but how
is it for this unlikely candidate to get
it if I'm in the living room ancient or
if I'm in the parlor mark I it continues
the puzzle that I have had
I wrote my dissertation on mark when I
was 30 years old I am no longer 30 years
old that's all I've been puzzling about
this stuff it continues that
insider-outsider oddity thing right
that's in some ways the guy who seems
most outside not only not part of my
immediate community not part of all the
history of Israel is led up to this can
say what no insider is said all the way
through truly this was the son of God
and I I think that can be threatening to
me if I'm proud of my inside mmus but if
I'm sitting there thinking well Peter
was my father-in-law and I've been part
of the inner server from the beginning
that's threatening to me if I've always
felt outside and wondered whether the
gospel can include me then I find it
comforting to discover that a guy just
is outside as I feel at the foot of the
cross can claim Christ as God's own son
maybe I'm brushed into this picture
maybe I'm brushed into yeah yeah and I
mean your your insider-outsider is
powerful because it you mentioned
earlier when Jesus is inside standing up
to the charges Peter's not lying yeah
here well while the Centurion is saying
you know this guy's the guy who's the
son of God Peter and Andrew and James
and John and the whole gang are often
thought about their orders all right so
the the likely candidates just aren't
the ones exactly yeah I think you're
right there's there's a there's good
news in that for all of us who can see
that we are outsiders in nature right
all right well thank you thank you